gohan
gohan i want to be stronger
i want to put a stop to these monsters
please train me so i can help you fight
trunks okay i'll do it
you won't regret this i promise good
we'll get stronger together and we'll
make sure our world is safe again
right trunks why are the androids doing
this
why are they killing people i don't know
but one thing's for sure
they're clearly enjoying it so gohan
back for more huh we're gonna kill you
this time
i won't die even if you destroy my body
i'll live on someone who'll become
stronger than me
and he will be the one to stop you once
and for all
it's been three years since you murdered
gohan i've spent that time getting
better so i can kill you
i'm done hiding from you you two are
finished better huh
i hate to break it to you but it still
won't be enough to stop us
you're not very bright if you really
think you can win now
not much longer not much longer until i
get my revenge
i am the ultimate android created by the
great
dr gero once i kill you
i'll head to the past and achieve my
perfect harm
cell you don't belong in this world
and all of those people my dad yours and
everyone else
they live on in you now trunks
if anyone's gonna bring peace it's you
you're our last hope
pay close attention to my heroic figure
begin the recording
i'm already filming here i come let's be
gentlemen
sandwich for you
for you it must be changed even if by
force
i will show you greatness that's a great
shot
it's not just my dream
thank you blah brother i love you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the far distant future a psionic
hormone was discovered in the human
brain
granting people extra sensory powers and
changing the world as we knew it
as humanity entered this new era
deranged mutants known as
others began to descend from the sky
with the hunger for human brains
highly resistant to conventional attack
methods
extreme measures needed to be taken to
battle the overwhelming threat
and preserve humanity those with acute
extra sensory
abilities known as psionics were our
only chance to fight the onslaught from
above
since then psionics have been scouted
for their talents
and recruited to the other suppression
force
also known as the osf humanities last
line of defense
the most powerful and popular members
are viewed as heroes
the scarlet guardians begin your
adventure
with either yuito sumaragi an energetic
recruit from a prestigious political
family
or kasane randall the mysterious scout
whose power and skill has gained
great notoriety among the osf
as their different experiences
interweave with each other
it is only then that you will reveal the
full story
and unlock all the mysteries of a brain
punk future caught between technology
and psychic abilities welcome to the
world of scarlet nexus
our story starts in suwo new himuka's
leading city
the center of its politics economy and
culture
its people thrive under the protection
of the soaring tower
that houses the other suppression force
headquarters
all habitants share a connection their
brains are linked to cynet
a huge network that bonds everyone and
everything
together for the good of its residents
in scarlet nexus you will become members
of the other suppression force
osf that are tasked with using their
powerful psionic abilities
to protect humanity the osf has been
recruiting new members
every year for the past 560 years
each one with special powers to help
fight back
against the others using the struggle
arm
system or sas a brain to brain
connection
with virtual cables members are able to
temporarily use
allies powers as a member of the osf
you will have to patrol around the
capital in places such as the old
osf hospital a hospital formerly
operating
on the outskirts of suo it was abandoned
after a large-scale assault by others
and has since been moved to a location
inside the capital yuito spent his youth
in and out of the facility due to his
frail disposition
and almost got killed by an other during
said attack
but a member of the osf rescued him
later he enlisted himself in the osf
and endured intensive training to one
day be able to help the citizens
of his city additional patrol routes
will have you check for others activity
in the abandoned subway suo 9 line
a transportation network stretching out
from underneath
to the neighboring cities the track was
abandoned along with the underground
industrial district
long ago after it sustained an attack by
the others
it is now a hazardous zone riddled with
cave-ins
cunad highway a highway built in the
remote region of cunad
will often be a destination for young
recruits
this highway much like the town it once
led to
has fallen into disuse given over to
others
and the famed kikuchiba a defunct
mercantile satellite town
of the suo capital the entire place is
divided into a layered structure and a
malfunctioning projector
shines a massive vision over the sky
making for an uncanny view on all of
your patrols
you will encounter others deranged
mutants
that descended from the sky highly
resistant to conventional attack methods
and defenses
tormented by constant pain they seek
brains of
living organisms to calm their madness
they rain down on earth from a fog
like phenomenon known as the extinction
belt
high up in the sky thankfully with the
advancement of technology
humanity has come up with measures to
predict
when they will fall and as such avoid
those casualties
some of recently spotted ones include
the vospas
if this pause were to get in the soil of
an everyday flower pot
you'd never be able to tell it apart
from a regular flower
when it spots prey from afar it will
jump with terrifying power and home in
with a kick attack
your telepathic powers should allow you
to face against this threat
easily however beware of the brawn yawn
this yarn crawls through the ground to
approach its prey
and leaps out with a powerful attack
although it looks like the creature
turns the ground to liquid and moves
through it
data analysis has shown that the other
itself is liquefied
and sinks into the ground
however do not engage if you ever find
yourself
in front of the court mort the most
massive recorded
other sighting in history please do not
engage
featuring a dual story scarlet nexus
allows you to play as unified a bright
and optimistic young recruit
who has a strong yet kind soul
he is the second son of the prestigious
sumeraghi family
whose ancestors were the founding
fathers of
he comes from a family of politicians
with his father
joe leading the current government and
his brother cato commanding the other
suppression force
he fights close quarters with the
combination of
quick sword attacks and psychokinesis
abilities
orca cool rational and
indifferent to those around her kasane
is an elite soldier
who graduated top of her class after
being scouted by the osf
for her exceptional fighting skills and
power
she tends to be unapproachable and
causes friction with those around her
but she can also be very kind to those
she has opened up to
she fights at range with a combination
of ranged
multi-blade attacks and psychokinesis
abilities
they are both able to use psychokinesis
the ability to move objects freely
by using their minds they will of course
be able to count on the support of their
allies and friends in battle
and their powers using sas hanabi and
her pyrokinesis
will be uito's first ally and sheeden
and his electrokinesis
throughout their adventures they will be
able to fight alongside
arashi and her hyper velocity kagero
and his invisibility kyoka and her
duplication
sugumi and her clairvoyance luca
and his teleportation and finally gemma
and his sclerokinesis cyanide's hyper
connectivity
to all your party will allow you to
protect new himuka
and humanity
[Music]
so
[Music]
the tarnished will soon return
guided by grace once
lost
the golden order is broken to its core
[Music]
[Music]
foul tarnished
in search of the elden ring
emboldened by the flame of ambition
someone must extinguish
thy flame
to be born
well
a lowly tarnished
playing as a lord
i command thee
brandish the elden ring
for all of us
pretty fancy place they got here harmony
and coexistence
between the renin's and the danon's
i'm dilcarus should you need my skills
on the battlefield
all i care for is maintaining peace
i'm captain kisara of the eldermen in
siagar
from now on when i fight i fight to
protect my dream
well this crew just gets bigger and
bigger
the renins seems the rumors you were
running with them were true
been looking for you
get the hell out of my realm this is
tannen's realm and it's ours understand
[Music]
is it over it's only just begun
[Music]
peggy 18.
satellite sweeps of the war zone have
uncovered what appears to be an
underground
storage facility but i strongly suspect
where chemical weapons are hidden so we
need to move fast
these people are not the enemy they're
just shepherds
is
oh
[ __ ] oh man what the
[ __ ] this is mailman 21 actual
all team sound off over
ah [ __ ]
the rest of the squad must be around
here somewhere
jason
jason i'm close man i'm coming
that don't sound too promising
uh
is this place
uh
that you nick
late that something
where on god's green earth that we
landed
we need to get back topside regroup with
the rest of the squad and signal for
medevac
this place ain't no weapon silo but it
sure is crawling with iraqis
nick
sergeant k pull yourself together
eyes wide
i saw something what do you mean shove
something
i mean it wasn't human
in a tunnel
should have never gotten off that hilo
don't do this nick not now i need you to
keep it together just a while longer
something's all right i know you can
feel it only thing i'm feeling is that i
got my work cut out with you
you ever seen anything like this the
hell is this place
yes i flunked history at school
tell me you don't feel it what nick i
feel what exactly
i'll know some
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna need some more muscle skipping
jim again
jesus i'm trying will you stop squirming
around oh it's bad
it's bleeding out we have to cut him
down right now hold tight buddy we got
you
nick here cut the wire
you keep lookout
look out for what jesus who the hell
loaded these packs
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] just happened
maurice
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
he's bleeding out you gotta take care of
this
let's give it to me straight not gonna
lie man
it's pretty bad shut up
hold it in man hold it the [ __ ]
together
more french kicked in
[Music]
this test will decide my assignment i
hope i'm in the same return as naomi
thinking about it now won't do me any
good i have to focus
i should be able to complete the
assignment as long as i'm calm
[Music]
naomi even complimented me on how well
it was suited for combat
next
hmm
it's done
i wonder if naomi is doing okay i'm sure
she is
she's one of the best
[Music]
[Music]
it seems like the exam is entered the
final stage
i feel like i'm in good form but i can't
relax just yet
uh
ah
huh
so i'm looking forward to you know a
different kind of tone
of presentation would you like me to
hold your hand in this presentation sure
puppy i'm okay with that you know
yeah if you're not familiar everybody of
course this is going to be uh
bandai name cup i still want to say
nameco bandai it's the when they changed
the name it was it was years ago and it
just
screws me up to this day uh of course
they're working with supermassive games
on the dark picture anthology a whole
bunch of different horror games that are
coming out in quick succession this is
the third one in the anthology already
but if you didn't know them before of
course super massive made until dawn a
breakout playstation hit that then led
to this deal
of course they've done matt and bedan
already uh now they did a little hope
and now it's time to see more of house
of ashes and so yeah
this one's an exciting different thing
right jackie well i have been
closely monitoring every trailer any
gameplay that has dropped on this and
it is so scary like i really cannot
emphasize that enough
um but for me it has to be more than
scary and it has to be more than these
terrifying aliens
for some reason the story really hits
with me
and you can also tell that they've
invested so much time into this project
and i'm really hoping we get more of an
inside look here because i
am on board and it is bloody and gory
and
aliens and right yeah i'm here right
yeah of course
not your cup of tea but a hundred
percent mine you know hey i'm here for
it don't watch it
opposing forces get dropped into
sumerian temple right and all sorts of
supernatural elements start popping up
we'll see what's going on here so golden
boy we need you
to get psyched up we need you to get
ready oh no i'm excited to watch it
i'm gonna be very scared i'm looking
forward to it i'm going to go over to
the media area
and i'm going to you know yeah i'm going
to be horrified because it's going to be
great it's time though
for our next presenter and here with
their 2021 e3
presentation is amco presents house
of ashes
[Music]
so
an ancient horror has awoken from its
slumber
and is hungry for blood shall we see
how many have fallen into shadow
satellite sweeps of the war zone have
uncovered what appears to be an
underground storage facility but i
strongly suspect
where chemical weapons are hidden so we
need to move fast
to descend into the unknown alone is
extremely brave
or extremely foolish
[Music]
of an abyss your survival depends on the
choices you make
they will be as a compass guiding you
through the unknown
what nightmare have these luckless souls
fallen into
keep look out look out
look out for what one by one
their lights will be snuffed up unless
you can find the means
to save them trapped beneath the earth
swallow we have to move let's go by the
boy
will you find the path to salvation
or be lost in the darkness
forever
[Applause]
[Music]
we're here at supermassive to talk about
the next game in the dark pictures
anthology
house of ashes i'm joined by exec
producer dan how you doing
hello thank you for joining us right so
let's start at the very start we're
going to be talking about
house of ashes for most of the interview
but for those that don't know
tell us about the dark pictures
anthology the dark pictures is a series
of
narrative story-driven branching horror
stories
each one is standalone they each tell a
different story completely separated
from the others
but within the same universe so there is
connection between them all
house of ashes is set at the end of the
iraq war in 2003
with links 4 000 years ago that set the
story up so tell us more about the
theme and themes i suppose within um
house of ashes
it starts off with a military unit
they've got some new technology that can
look for weapons of mass destruction
underground they think they've
identified something in the zagos
mountains in iraq
and then as part of that they come into
conflict with an iraqi unit
and there's a pitched firefight and then
the two groups are plunged underground
there's an earthquake of some sort and
it's revealed that there's a hidden
temple underground you know these big
massive structures but
these different groups they're all
separated radio contact is lost and
they're submerged in this black
darkness where on god's greener than we
landed
and then they're going to start hearing
things and seeing things and people are
going to start disappearing
what the [ __ ] just happened so this time
it's a very real threat
all of the dark pictures games they all
pull something from from real life or
from history from fact
what's the case with the myth or
historical part of house of ashes
so we love looking at um looking at and
reading
myths and legends and stories and doing
our research and we know our fans love
it as well because there's something
that they can link into afterwards and i
love doing that when i'm playing games
and watching movies myself
so this one's set 4 000 years ago the
acadian empire
and this terrible evil that happened we
had this self-proclaimed god king
naram sin and he essentially cursed his
people he sacked this temple and
brought famine and devastation to his
own people and so a lot of the history
is lost but we've we've done a lot of
research about it and then we had a lot
of happy accidents that linked into the
story we wanted to tell
and the fun thing for us is we get to we
get to do our own take on it we get to
twist it and
obviously we've made our own truth from
it at the end of the
sneak peek the trailer we saw
monsters tell us a bit more about what's
going on there the military unit that
you're playing as they don't really know
what they're coming up against
they're not human they're bigger they're
larger they're faster
the team aren't going to know if there's
one or two of them or hundreds or
thousands of them and that's kind of a
threat with this you know they've got
guns
maybe they could try and take one of
them down but maybe there's another one
around the corner maybe there's a group
of them and maybe they're going to get
ambushed maybe they're like a cluster
exactly yeah a nest as it were and it's
been really fun to work on and see these
things move around and how horrific they
can be
they're different to us they perceive
the world in a different way getting
little snippets of it in the darkness
and
was that did i see that was it something
that moved uh or is it actually just one
of the other
soldiers that's stuck in the catacombs
who's there
we like to try and misdirect people on
things you know that did you see
something did you not
and that's a great thing within horror
that you think you're going to be scared
right now and we're not going to scare
you now we'll scare you in a minute
we're not expecting it
it's always coming yeah always so should
we expect a huge amount of
peril in the game definitely um we love
to do it um you know it's fun fun for us
to work on
it's horrific as it is and it's we know
that our fans love it as well
so yeah there's at least 60 unique
deaths and there's a whole ton of
variation on that as well
so mowing and some of the others you're
going to see
different things happening to them
depending on how you play out you know
getting ripped and shredded and torn and
because there's a firefight there's
going to be bullets flying as well and
all kinds of stuff
and it's not just the deaths it's the
gore that goes along with it and
you know lots of blood wicked it sounds
absolutely terrifying
i'm in not gonna lie man
it's pretty bad what differences have
you made or changes have you made to the
to the game player mechanics for house
of ashes
we were always evolving the dark
pictures um we listened to a lot of the
feedback from our fans um and and also
our team what they want to do how they
want to push things forward
so we tried some stuff in in little hope
with um you know
more camera control 360 cameras in
certain parts and we've really leaned on
that again and it really works well
in house of ashes lots of the game is
set underground and so these sort of
corridors which are really tight and
impressive creepy yeah indeed so yeah
so we've had to learn because you take
away the fixed cameras
and that takes away some opportunities
for horror but we've had to learn new
tricks to scare people and
you know ramp up the tension and you
know the chance for jump scares which
you know some people love
we've also got a new torch mechanic so
um you know it's military theme so these
guys gonna be walking around with
weapons
with torches mounted on them we love the
lighting that we do this
really inky black darkness that we have
and sort of the contrast to the bright
areas
and so you're going to need to lean on
that torch to allow you to see
where you're going what the threat is
and that kind of stuff
we've also done things like added
difficulty settings for this game so
in little hope we added you know qte
warning icons as an example and we've
got some really good positive feedback
about that but also some people want to
turn that off
we want to allow you to play the game in
your way so with our accessibility
settings and difficulty settings
if you want to have a more casual
experience you can change those settings
still most of your characters are going
to end up dead but you know that's
that's spoilers yeah
but that's what we come here for that's
okay we can deal with it so i've got to
ask
what was it like working with ashley so
ashley was fantastic
she researched rachel she understood her
when she came on the set which is so
refreshing she knew her inside out
and rachel is a flawed character so she
brought that through so fantastically
the rest of the cast were fantastic as
well when we were looking for joey
shaleem helped me you didn't tell me
this because
you'd flip your [ __ ] we want you to
connect to these characters and
understand them as humans we want them
to seem real because they're real to us
you know we spend a long time designing
them and
and i don't mind if you hate anyone the
individual character because
you don't like everyone in real life but
maybe you'll like them when you see the
journey they go on
maybe you'll like them once they're dead
and yeah and you feel bad about it
differently
yeah but also we want you to save them
we want you to try and save them you
know we know that some people want to
get everyone killed straight away and
that's fine that's
their play through that's what they want
to do but you know can you get everyone
out alive
and save as many as you can there's a
lot of replayability there indeed
forever i like that so last question
favorite scene favorite scene so um
saleem now iraqi soldier and jason
kolczyk one of the marines
that's there there's a way that that can
play out and a sort of
contest between them and you can make it
go in a number of different ways
the enemy of my enemy is my friend it's
really emotional seeing them film it i
was lucky enough to be there
and they've seen that come through in
game i think we've got something there i
think that's gold
um and then of course i love scaring
people so i love the jump scares i love
the
the moments of tension uh that we bring
we can't hold you in that moment so
we've got some fantastic jokes in there
as well
to allow you to relax for a moment
before we scare you again
to take your mind off the imminent
threat i like that
dan thank you so much this has been
really cool to talk about and i'm sure
you know i i'm
excited and terrified in equal part and
everyone else is just excited
i'm sure and it's been a real pleasure
to speak to you and i can't wait to get
into people's heads
before we dive in the house of ashes see
how scared you got of course we want to
thank razer for being one of the e3 20
21 sponsors of course
giving us these tired old blades nobody
cares about but this blade 14
girl rtx 3080 built right in of course
the razor i'm taking that
thank you so much now i'm taking that
okay we'll fight okay well
we've done it before you know what i'll
take the hand-me-down i'll be i'll i'll
be little brother i'll take the outdated
nobody wants these anymore right it
doesn't work ah golden boy you just saw
the dark pictures anthology
yeah yeah yeah your first uh a glimpse
of it we have some reactions
from you is what you do they were
recording you they said you were a
little scared
not terrified not terrified thankfully
uh because you know it was just a
you know a normal normal trailer which
is fine
there's my face you're unsettled for
sure yeah oh yeah no you don't like that
yeah i don't like that no i don't know
not a fan of that one i don't know
nope nope nope nope yeah i think that
was one of the jumps
dark picture anthology at house of ashes
uh so supermassive games in liverpool uk
making that one being published by
bandai
namco i it's i personally have fallen
off
uh the dark pictures anthology very
guilty
but i did love uh until dawn i had a
great time with that one
uh persia what about you what's your
experience with dog pictures
i played man of medan which was
interesting because i hadn't really
played until dawn so i didn't know what
to expect even hopping into that one but
there was some sort of satisfaction kind
of going through it all and seeing
everyone
die um yeah so now
i'm thinking about how they're talking
about all of the bloody deaths coming in
house of ashes i'm like hmm let's see if
we can run this back
i was gonna say because uh yeah the
devil's saying that like obviously there
are people who
you're gonna wanna kill or at least
there are always players who are going
to
try and kill everyone um i i am one of
the
i am a player who will try and save as
many as i can so i can't really identify
tam what's your experience with these
ones yeah i played a bunch of mana medan
and i went to like a they kind of like
spoke to the developers behind it and
i think the the thing about it for me
currently is the ambition
that the developers have for it
especially coming off until dawn and the
critical
claim that they got for that and what
they've executed on has been slightly at
odds with each other
i feel like they've got the spark of
something and it's just not quite
hitting in terms of one thing or another
sometimes it's like the writing's not
all there sometimes
like the atmosphere is not quite there
or like the decision making moments are
perhaps amazing
this one definitely feels like it's
starting to look like it could be the
most
interesting especially thematically
narratively so i'm really excited to
jump back into it and see how they deal
with it like the idea of a kind of like
military setting where
this weird supernatural thing is
happening and how that impacts the
people around it the mental states of
them and then them knowing that
in terms of gameplay they needed to
shake it up a bit i think that is
really good a really good sign going
into
this new entry in that series
so i am i am definitely more inclined to
keep an eye on it and check it out when
it comes out for sure
yeah i think to your point there if you
think about until dawn until dawn i
remember
when that one was announced what came
out 2015 i remember it
being announced like way way way ahead
and it was very very different i
i think i remember like a playstation
move game like you use the ps move as
sort of your torch or flashlight
and then ultimately like the way that
game evolved and so
maybe supermassive have learned
something and they're just kind of
making these shorter
experiences that are still you know full
to the frame of player choice
but are maybe less ambitious in all the
millions of different permutations you
could potentially get in until dawn
and probably over-exaggerating when i
say millions but definitely a lot
um so it's good to see and also means
that they can be a little bit quicker
when it comes to reacting to things like
player feedback
um as you can see they're changing their
accessibility options which is always a
fantastic thing
to hear and see developers do but also
changing uh the way that
they are adding like difficulty settings
and they're changing the camera
stuff because i loved until dawn in the
way that it had like this filmic
quality it was every shot seemed very
very deliberate and it's obviously you
know a throwback to something like
uh resident evil where you sort of have
the tank controls and the very
deliberately posed cameras uh but that
does mean that like some players are not
going to enjoy that and so i'm intrigued
to see them experiment with a freer
camera
for this one the story hasn't
particularly gravity just yet
uh because i have never heard of the
acadian empire
uh british schooling unfortunately did
not
uh go that far but it sounds like it
sounds intriguing
like a court that kind of ends up all
bloody and full of betrayal i love that
stuff um
persia what do you make of the setting
and the fact that actually like they
i didn't realize actually tisdale was in
it obviously they always have like a big
name like sean ashmore
uh rami malek uh hayden panettiere like
they always have these big names and now
ashley tisdale i know i didn't know
either until we were watching
the presentation and obviously
you know i my guilty pleasure was high
school musical back in the day
so i'm very happy it
[Music]
we'll see that out of house of ashes
rising to the top because
like you were mentioning before there
are a lot of elements where they might
have fallen short before and i feel like
they're kind of addressing all of that
now we saw from the mocap sessions
and even hearing like the voice acting
and how um people like ashley tisdale
approach
becoming a character it looks very
involved so i'm interested to see more
and they were mentioning oh you know we
got to find new ways to scare
people but they definitely had no issues
scaring me
in the ones that i played so i'm like do
you know
do you but for everyone else who's you
know much tougher than i am when it
comes to horror games
they are specifically looking towards
you guys to
seemingly make scarier things happen and
i'm just gonna have to brace myself for
it
uh house of ashes is coming out later
this year so this is the final day of
the official e3 broadcast we still have
two more days
of game sports play for all so it's
going to be packed full
of developer interviews exclusive
trailers
gameplay as well as sessions with some
well-known faces
uh from around the industry to chat
about the big reveals
from this week but today like because
the stream ain't going nowhere today we
also have
the gamespot showcase which is uh
something that tam helped put together
in collaboration with the mix tam do you
wanna tell us a little bit about
it yeah so the gamespot showcase is
something that
is quite near and dear to our hearts and
my heart specifically as well
to get it out of the way because i know
what it's like to go into a showcase not
knowing what's there
this isn't about triple a experiences
this isn't you're not going to get an
elden ring here you won't see halo pop
up you won't have any
aaa games like that however the games
that are going to be there are really
cool they're really interesting
i hand selected a bunch of them myself
and my approach to it was like
i'm gonna pick a bunch of games that i
know my friends are gonna like and uh
and there's
games in there that i thought about when
when i saw them it was like oh this
person that i work with is going to love
this
well this person i know is going to love
this and they're all games that are tied
together
thematically or in terms of purpose in
that
they are exploring interesting subject
matter that is often
not explored in triple a games or
they're created by teams of diverse
perspectives
or they're created by you know teams
that want to have a
message all the games that are designed
to be uplifting and cozy
and that kind of stuff this is the kind
of stuff that i
think is gonna be like i said not
blockbuster games that you're gonna be
like holy moly this is gonna be game of
the year i mean some of them will be
game of year i'm sure for a lot of
people
but it's the smaller experiences that
are going to be meaningful to you in
your life and
and they will either make you feel good
about playing them or they'll make you
think when you put them down
or you'll want to speak to someone and
be like you should check this game out
small indie game that's really really
neat and it's split up into an
it's an hour and um there are four
interviews that are going to happen
during
the that whole hour and therefore four
games that
come from people or their four ideas or
get four games that i really like stuck
with me and i wanted to explore them
so they're like maybe five or six
minutes each the per
interview in between that we're just
gonna be talking about here's a bunch of
games
and you're gonna show we're gonna show a
quick hits of trailers for these games
so it's quite a lean i think um showcase
i very much myself and randy and
the team at the mix that worked on it
were very cognizant of the fact that
of the pacing of it we didn't want to
have people like
falling asleep watching these these kind
of showcases and
you know not really giving stuff people
to things giving people things to get
excited about so
we made an effort to make sure there's
always going to be something that
someone watching there is going to be
like oh that's cool that's cool or in
as in the interview sections there's
stuff there that you're going to
say like oh that's an interesting
perspective or subject matter
so yeah please do check it out and share
it and let people know this is the first
time we've done anything like this and
i hope that people will take to it
because i'd love to do more of it
yeah well that is today at 3 30 uh p.m
or 3 35 i think it is if you want the
specific timings uh we'll be streaming
the whole thing
uh you can also find it on the esa's
broadcast e3's broadcast
uh but it's gonna be a good time and
tam's put a lot of hard work
uh as well as the folks at the mix uh to
put it all together so make sure you
watch
that's not all that we have today the
official
e3 awards are also happening
um persia i mean what do you think is
gonna be what do you think is the game
that is gonna like walk away with the
most awards today
i mean it's tough because
when i first started watching all the
press conferences
as they were coming by every conference
had something
that caught my eye but you know i got a
stick with my roots like
the halo multiplayer looked really
really good it got me super excited and
honestly i've watched
i've watched it so many times slowing it
down looking at everything seeing what's
what's new what's coming back and it
just reminds me of
the old days when i used to play so much
halo 2 and like
you know breaking the game down with
friends and i'm ready to run it all back
in 2021
you know holiday season is coming so
honestly i gotta give all my love to
halo
even though there were a ton of games
that were really cool like
my second favorite is probably red fall
so far i really love the cinematic i
love the theme
um you know some friends of mine we've
been kind of trying out like a vtm
and stuff and there was also a vtm game
too there's just so much
this is hard to pin down and it's hard
to depend on anything but
halo is definitely going to be it for me
time what about you you know the answer
to this
well does it does it count though
because it was in a different show
i do not care in the last month the best
thing to happen to the world has been an
elden ring trailer
and a release date we've got a release
date and a trailer
that is wild um elder ring is yeah it
is of the of the event of the e3 season
the summer games mess elder ring is my
pick but if i had to pick outside of
that
i would have said halo but persia locked
it down so
and i appreciate that at least it's
getting started
but um metroid metroid
looks amazing i'm so excited for that
advance was by is back and
i'm so excited for that as well and
replaced as well i think is one that
really really stood out to me
such a cool looking game um but if i had
to pick one of those
metroid dread easy yeah i mean
it's been i don't know like i've been
sort of trying to make a list as we've
gone through e3 about games that i've
really got my eye on definitely elden
ring
absolutely red fall halo as well breath
of the wild too
mario plus rabbids also i i'm weirdly
excited about rocksmith
plus even though like
it's a piece of training software i
suppose but i think for me i think
persia you kind of nailed it when you're
talking about red fall like
anything that arcane makes i'm gonna
just
absolutely eat up and i love that this
obviously it is a
cgi trailer not indicative of gameplay
at all but the world
that they look like they're working in
and building
it's always my favorite part of arcane
games is the strength of the world
building meets the strengths of the
artistic direction
and how those fuse together and meld
with gameplay
and i love the the way that they craft
those things and because it makes you
feel like you're in this believable
place
um so i'm very very excited to see more
of red four um
but if you want something that we saw
gameplay of
uh i don't know like
i also thought guardians looked really
cool like i also interviewed the team
behind it they seemed so passionate
about it and we had a real fun time
that'll be
shown as part of our play for all
showcase uh like either tomorrow or
thursday
um but guardians looks genuinely fun i
love that it's kind of they're doing the
the marvel spider-man thing of taking a
pre-existing character characters that
everyone loves and like putting their
own spin on it so it's not something
that we'll have seen in the mcu
or um necessarily red obviously there
will be characters that we'll recognize
so i'm just excited to see more of that
one especially that soundtrack too
because like the license soundtrack
really got me as soon as i heard joan
jett i was like yeah that's me
i'm in um i loved it too
i'm not gonna lie i'm a sucker for groot
all right
i will just throw it out there i'm such
a sucker for groot
and watching it was really exciting and
i want to see more i want to see
you know what else we can do like am i
going to see maybe
baby groot at some point like really
heartbreaking but exciting at the idea
of it happening
and yeah great it looked really good
gamora she kind of
has her outfit that's more closer to her
older design and not really her mcu
design which is my personal favorite
because she was my main and marvel
infinite who also has she looks like the
infinite version
yeah she looks like the internet version
the moment she popped up i was like
that's infinite
i've seen it i love it so i'm looking
forward to it too
yeah uh any other games that caught your
eye tam
uh you know i think that's pretty much
the
the uh there's also the kurosawa game
which i'm forgetting the name of because
my
memory is shot at this point but um i
kind of into the
the uh that that looked really really
cool um
but other than that yeah i think i need
to go back and really check out like 12
minutes got a release date and i'm hyped
as hell about that
um but i want to go back and watch a
bunch of those
starfield we could say starfield as well
i guess like nothing in terms of
gameplay but
the vibe of it is was really cool and
i'm excited for that
but yeah i think all those games that
are coming to game pass
are my games of the show and game pass
is the game
shane pass is my game of the show
it's also really strange to hear about
like um
e3 awards with no one going hands-on
with anything
like because that was always the sort of
the best bit of e3 is like walking
around the booths
and having hands-on with the games there
and then seeing all the awards kind of
stack up so it's it's very
it's a weird one but i'm excited i think
halo is going to walk away with a lot i
think they've really turned it around
um the sentiment definitely seems to be
just
way higher from that first reveal that
they had last summer
um so i'm stoked for that um
we should talk about what else we're
doing as a part of play for all
um so we i have two days of live streams
starting tomorrow uh 9 a.m i believe uh
running until about two or three
so we're kind of all gonna be anchoring
anchoring like tam
persia and i kurt dave uh gonna be
popping on as well
and then we're gonna be chatting about
the interviews and the hands-on
and uh all of the gameplay and trailers
that we're gonna be showing
i don't know how public our schedule is
yet
time maybe you can i don't think it's i
don't think it's super public but what
we can say is around
e3 we're usually given access to a bunch
of you know
executives and people who you would have
seen on stage at e3 or developers that
are
key minds behind some of these games and
as always we
we did interviews with them we spoke to
them and um
we've kind of been storing that up for
the next couple days now that the uh
the hubbub of the press conferences and
the reveals is out of the way now you'll
be able to really dig
into some of the games that have been
shown and also
hear from the people that are behind it
so we will have interviews with the
likes of pete hines and we'll have
interviews with nintendo folks and folks
that are working at um
working on games so is well worth tuning
in over the next couple of days
yeah like lucy said we're all gonna be
there as well and
it's kind of that the storm has passed
now so we're kind of calming down so
we're just gonna have fun with it we're
gonna
keep it easy breezy maybe get a bit
weird so we'll make sure to make it
entertaining for you
as well as it being uh informative and
insightful from the people that we bring
on
and obviously loads of trailers as well
so a lot of exclusive trailers as well
so you'll get
a good good helping of everything you
want from an e3 for the next two to two
days
and i mean i know you said that we're
slowing down but we're not really
so if you i remember what we did for
playful last year it was a
six week long event uh where we had
sort of the e3 side of it we had like
uh every major press conference in that
time so obviously everyone was more
spread out than just being an e3 week
and so
six weeks long and if we weren't doing
something about new releases
or press conferences we were running
charity streams we raised a lot of money
last year
for black lives matter and direct relief
covert support
so this year that's coming back in
earnest we
are partnering with ablegamers to raise
money for them
fantastic charity that helps people with
disabilities
um just play games and like their
mission
is is so strong and we were talking to
steve swann
who is going to be joining us on a live
stream next week and
the fact that gaming helps bring people
together it's like
just this joyous activity that like we
know you're all gamers because otherwise
why would you be here
um to partake in and like especially
over quarantine it's helped to bring so
many people together so ablegamers
works not only in accessibility
consulting but also
uh in changing pieces of hardware so
that people with disabilities
can play um i mean i know this is like
it's like their tagline is so that
everyone can play and that is such a
strong mission
so we are gonna be raising money to uh
go
towards the uh spawn together initiative
that steve's put together
um tam do you wanna talk a little bit
about what we've got planned
yeah so the spawn together initiative is
it's kind of this
community effort to get to i believe
it's one million dollars raised and like
lucy said they
work on making peripherals and making
stuff easier but they also have an
educational track for the things that
they do where they have
helped people um kind of educating
himself on how to design games to be
more accessible so it's a super
important cause and
to support that course we've brought in
friends from around the industry
and you know there are people that
are we're fans of and we wanted to work
with and we're excited to work with and
we're gonna say who they are a few of
them but stuff is fluid people are
always moving in and out so
you know you never know there could be
some last minute changes but obviously
we are going to be partnering with our
friends at giant bomb
um we're going to have a stream with
those that crew there
uh we're going to have jake baldino is
going to be here from game ranks
and we're going to be playing some metal
gear and we're going to be doing some
really goofy stuff with
metal gear if you're a fan of anime you
will
obviously know the youtuber super eye
patch wolf
and super patchwolf was very kind enough
last year to
hang out with us and and you know play a
game for the first time he'd never
played
um what remains of edith finch and he
wanted to play that on stream and we did
that
so we've brought him back and we've
teamed him up with
uh internet sensation one of the
smartest minds
in in my eyes around right now h bomber
guy so
it's going to be me lucy h bomber guy
and super eyebatch wolf we're going to
be
playing heave ho and we're going to try
and have an intelligent discussion at
the same time
beyond that we've got the kind of funny
crew um
coming on we'll have greg snowback mike
blessing
uh and we're gonna be playing we're
gonna be playing what are we playing
again
knocking knockout city we're playing
knockout which was
a ton of fun um and we've also got uh
steve swann from ablegamers joining us
as well
and uh john robertson is going to be
doing his incredible
dark room with us next tuesday which is
like an interactive choose your own
adventure
it's wickedly twisted uh he streams it
quite frequently i was on
he did a charity stream the other week
and i popped on and
i had the best time and it's like all
interactive with twitch he does some
really cool stuff there so
you won't want to miss it we're going to
be streaming twice daily
uh 10 a.m pt until 12 p.m pt is kind of
like the morning slot
and then uh 2 p.m pt til 4 p.m
the afternoon slot except the friday is
just one big
long stream with us and our friends at
giant bomb
very excited for that one uh because
obviously like
i mean tam right there is repping the
giant bomb right now
unintentionally i see always no i did it
on purpose
i was like i'm going to wear my giant
bomb t-shirt today because i need i need
the energy
but yeah those are just a few of them
we've got way more people lined up
um it's going to be fun and like i said
we're raising money we've set our goal
uh we you know as as gamespot does we
shoot for the moon
um we've set a goal of fifty thousand
dollars so
please do share the the link uh is
available right now
um you can start leave it's on screen
yeah it's
it should be on screen um tinyurl.com
playful20 yep there it is you'd love to
see it uh tinyurl.complayforall2021
please if you can donate you know it's
going in there if you can't share it
around let people know
i'm sure you know people who will be
very very much up for um donating to a
good cause so
share while you can let's let's try and
get as close to
50k as we can if not hit it
yeah i mean it's gonna be a lot of fun
uh we've put a lot of heart and soul and
blood and sweat and tears into
uh arranging not only e3 but sort of
like a week of charity stuff
uh we're gonna like blow up some steam
have fun
uh with some faces that you may know and
recognize and also raise
a bunch of money for charity so that's
our plan for the next uh
week in a bit because you thought e3 was
over today it's definitely not
um like i said so the rest of this
afternoon we have the game gamespot play
for all
showcase we have the e3 awards uh
we're gonna wrap up here very quickly
but later on today we've got kurt
and persia back to do the sort of end of
day wrap
so before we go just now uh what have
been your biggest
uh like the most fun thing you saw today
persia
warioware oh my gosh i played so much
warioware back in the day they had the
most random mini games this was
definitely around where i was like mini
games are
life and warioware fit right in that
pocket
and the fact that they announced that i
was like what and then i can play with
friends what
i was like this is perfect i love it was
not expecting it
i like got hype in the group chat and
they were like this is for business but
you know important stuff only version
i'm like i'm sorry but like what were
you aware
so that was definitely the most fun
announcement for me
all right and now we're gonna throw back
over to the esa stream
uh we will be right here after all of
the awards and stuff are done to
wrap up e3 we'll see you then
you